[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein tolles bisher zum
ramadan und zwar könnt ihr das zum
beispiel zum damals an beidem also zum
fest an machen
ich habe hier nämlich eine hellwache
gemacht helfer habe ich ja bereits vor
kurzem selbst zubereitet das ist diese
masse hier ein richtig tolles bisher
auch ein toller brotaufstrich und daraus
habe ich dann diese torte gemacht für
die torte könnt ihr natürlich auch
helfer kaufen müsst ihr nicht selber
machen schmeckt beides super lecker und
vor allem habe ich das ganze im blech
gebacken
da kann man wirklich tolle kleine
portionen aufzuschneiden und das ist
beim ramadan fest immer ganz wichtig
weil man nämlich ganz viele menschen
besucht und dann kann man nicht so viel
essen und jeder gast möchte nur ein
kleines stückchen probieren und ist
wirklich eine ganz tolle und besondere
torte und ich starte zuerst einmal mit
dem kuchen boden und zeigen hier die
zutaten für den teig brauche ich 450
gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt und
eine prise salz 150 gramm flüssige
butter
hier habe ich bereits 100 gramm butter
schokolade und haselnüsse gerieben 150
gramm mehl und hier habe ich noch
eineinhalb teelöffel backpulver und
einen halben teelöffel zimt zu essen
nehmen die jetzt die eier und die werden
gemeinsam mit dem zucker salz und
vanille extrakt für etwa fünf minuten
cremig verrührt und es geht am besten
wenn die eier schönen zimmer waren sind
[Musik]
gibt es die eier zucker wasser schön
cremig jetzt kommen noch die gemahlenen
haselnüssen und die geriebene schokolade
dazu die mutter kommt mit ryan mehl
backpulver und sind kann ich hier kurz
heimischen und dann kommt die zutaten
auch mit rein und alles wird kurz
verrührt
[Musik]
wer möchte kann jetzt einen runden
tortenring nehmen oder einen eckigen ich
mache das ganze jetzt eckig denn an
ramadan ist es immer ganz schön wenn man
kleinere portionen anbieten kann und es
geht bei einer eckigen torte eben etwas
besser jetzt zu vorsichtig verstreichen
und dann kann der teig gebacken werden
und ich kann in der zwischenzeit schon
mal den pudding herstellen
[Musik]
ich verbinde 350 ml milch 3 eigelb 50
gramm zucker 40 gramm stärke und 200
gramm helfer ich verwende jetzt mein
selbstgemachtes helfer aber ihr könnt
auch helfer aus dem supermarkt kaufen
aus dem türkischen oder im deutschen
supermarkt in der türkischen ecke und
zwar ist heller ein dessert aus
sesampaste ihr könnt aber auch wenn ihr
das nicht wollt einfach sesampaste hier
noch zu fügen und etwas mehr zucker
denn zucker ist und nicht so viel jetzt
gebe ich etwas mädels in den topf dann
kommt das eigelb dazu zucker und stärke
und jetzt kann ich das ganze mal kurz
klümpchen frei verrühren
es kommt die übrige milch mit rein und
ich kann den pudding jetzt während der
berührend einmal aufkochen lassen bei
mittel hoher hitze
[Musik]
jetzt sieht man schon wieder ein putting
eindeckt das geht von der einen auf die
nächste sekunde wirklich schnell und
dann macht gleich und dann könnt ihr
nämlich den pudding vom herd
herunternehmen das hell wahrnehmen und
entweder klein schneiden oder einfach
mit den fingern zerbröseln und dann kurz
einrühren
[Musik]
jetzt hat sich alles gut verbunden jetzt
kann ich die masse umfüllen in einem
flachen teller mit verschaltete folie
direkt an der oberfläche abdecken damit
einfach keine haut entsteht und dann
lasse ich den pudding abkühlen
in der zwischenzeit wird auch der boden
von dem kuchen abkühlen und dann geht es
gleich weiter
[Musik]
jetzt ist alles schön abgekühlt und
jetzt kann ich zuerst einmal den pudding
glatt rühren
ich würde mir gerne durch ein sieb
streichen aber ich habe pistazien mit
drin von daher funktioniert es nicht
also einfach kurz mit dem schneebesen
durchrühren
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich in einer separaten
schüssel 400 gramm sahne mit etwas
sonderbar steif schlagen und dann die
cremes verbinden
ich habe die sahne jetzt nur halb steif
schlagen lassen kann jetzt die maschine
auf mittlere stufe oder auf niedriger
stufe nehmen und langsam den pudding
einrühren
so verhindert einfach dass die sahne
gerinnt und so lange geschlagen wird
[Musik]
und wenn die creme und nicht ganz fest
ist die zwar noch ein bisschen an
dann können die aber trotzdem noch ein
bisschen sonderbar zufügen
[Musik]
und jetzt verteile ich die halver creme
auf dem boden des er bereits abgekühlt
ich habe ja noch ein bisschen mit
kaffeegetränk so bekommen auch noch den
kaffeegeschmack mit rein
[Musik]
und mit einer tankkarte bekommt ihr
alles schön glatt und so kann ich die
torte jetzt mindestens vier stunden
kühlen gerne auch über nacht vorher
natürlich abdecken und danke man sie
fertig dekorieren
nach der kür zeit können sie die torte
dann aus dem back rahmen herauslösen und
da gebe ich jetzt so ein bisschen
flüssige schokolade drüber
dafür habe ich kuvertüre klein gehackt
oder in einem gefrierbeutel einfach in
warmes wasser gehängt und die kuvertüre
einfach über die torte fließen lassen
jetzt kommt noch etwas heller drüber und
esther bröselig einfach mit den händen
und nun könnt ihr es zu schneiden wie
ihr möchtet ich bin zu kleine rechtecke
immer ganz hübsch aber auch zum beispiel
rautenförmig zuschneiden und ich freue
mich jetzt drauf denn der mutter
telefoniert gerade draußen irgendwo und
jetzt nicht probieren so zum glück ist
dem rat mit lecker die torte ist nicht
so süß und das selber macht eine richtig
tolle konsistenz auf dieser putting
creme hast du wirklich super lecker
nicht so süß
also geschmack die einwandfreien ihr
könnt auch gerne mehr kaffee nehmen wenn
ihr café fansite dann trinkt den boden
noch ein bisschen mehr ich find's super
lecker ihr könnt es toll vorbereiten und
dann euren gästen servieren
viel spaß beim nachmachen oder einen
schönen ramadan wünsche ich euch bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss
[Musik]